وشو من غريبه غطت وجوههم واجسادهم في
تقليد وتوارث منذ عشرات السنين واصطياد
الرؤوس اعضائهم سر تحملهم للالم الشديد
انهم شعب الناقه
تعالوا معنا لنتعرف على قصه جديده من
عادات وشعوب
بين الهند
نجوم بوك
وهي واحده من قبائل متعدده كونت شعب
الناقه
بعد خوض احدى الحروب المحليه رفيع جمجمه
لاحدى ضحاياه وهو امر كان منتشرا في حروب
تلك القبائل سابقا بهذه المناسبه ومن قبيل
الافتخار بالنصر امسك به حين كان طفلا
وثبت بالقوه لو الشمال للمره الاولى
اوه ندوشه
عندما كان طفله اقتداء بالنساء اسرتها
الجيل
السابق في اصطياد الرؤوس اعدائهم
وتحملهم لالم الوشم
اييه بتاعك غلط
[موسيقى]
بحروب سابقه لم تعد موجوده الان
قبائل الناجت عيش حياتنا غايه في الفقر
يسرون على اقدامهم لايام للوصول الى احدى
المدن القريبه كما يكتفي معظم اطفالهم
بدراسه ابتدائيه ولا تصل الكهرباء الا
لنصف مساكنهم تقريبا
ورغم كل هذه الظروف لانهم يعيشون على
الفخر والتغني بماضيهم حتى اليوم
[موسيقى]